THATG
COITRYATE MOSKVA,
THE RUSSIANS SAY  LIARS, BUT TH
RUSSIANSAY ISANK ON S OWN.OF CL
EVIDENCE AS TO WHAHA
>>ra THAT IT
SA IT A TRAGUSEAPOT OUCOUNTRY.WT
TO
THAT. WEAPONS
FERA ATTACKED OUUNTRY HE BETTE
LESS POWERTH
ARE.
THIS IALL, AND IT HE MOS
HTELL. HE NEWSIAN OFFENSIVEEASL
YOURS  WARNED ULD LOOK
AS BWA.TTLE OF KYARE YOU GOING
FOR THNBAStor: FS IMPORTANT DIF
SAFETY, FIRS
GROU LOCATED IN DONBAS IS
E T
HA.
WANTS TO ENCIRCLE THEM AND
DEEMS NE00IT IS 44,000 PROFESSI
RY MEND A T R THIS IS WHY IT ITT
FOR US T T OE MOST.
THIS IRY IMPORTANTUS NOTO ALLOOI
IT CAN S
THERE WILL BE SEVERAL BATT
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
AK I
COURSEF WA
I DON'T TRUST THE RUSS AEADERSH.
AND THEY LEFT D EROUGHT THEM OFF
D FROM
IS VERY IMPONY MY'RE ABLE TOREAM
MIGHT USE TA NLEAR  IN THISRRIE
>> NOT ONLY ME.
THE COUNO L OF
BECAU KNOWT CAN BE NOT
RE INFORMATION, BUT IT CAN BE TH
GIN TOAK ONE OR ANOTR BATT
NUCLR E CHEM
ISSUES, OULD DO IT, THEYOU. CAN
NOTH.
BET ATT A  TRA NOT
LYORKRAINE, FOR ALL THE
WORLD.
I THINK SO.
TralaA
POSSIBILY M USING THE
NOBODY EXPECERE A LL UKRAINE  TN
NOW THATHE AFULL-SCA ID KILLINGE
THEM TO EVADE THWHERE E' MY UII.
THIS IS A FACT, ANIT
HAEND THATGIS OMETHINGT
ACCORDING TO PLAY CAN USEANUCLEA
ANTHS WHDAAIMSF
UN
AREADUNN USE CL
>> HOW BAD AREWH
P THE PEF  T IS
VERY DIFFICULTMA
'S THAT THIN
WITH EACH PASSING DAY IT'S
MORE
UNFORTUN
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
I WILL NOTTHWI RUSSIAN
HAVE TREATED
RIUPOL, THE RUSSIAMILITARYERE A
DIMON PUNYONE GU
WO T L.F THOUSANDS  OUSAND, TENO
NOKNE.FT NDO, , AND WE DO
AM SEVERAL S OF CHILDREN.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM, WHETHE GOOD
RTUNAT TATN  AND RDING WHAT POPA
REMAINED THERE, WE ALS
HA DEFINITIVANSWER.Y THEYAYRE R
WE'RE TALKOUT CIAN W
DE, T MI
LDREN DE
BEE  DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO GO TO THE UKRAINIAN SIDE,
UKRAINIAN-CONTROLLEDE.KNOW THE .
E  DIFFICULT AND MORE  COMPLED.
A LOTH WE
HAVE TO CHECANWHIC
UKRAINIA OR UKRAINIAN ANS HAVE W
HE IORE HAVE, IT IFICULT TBO CI
WHERE
TOWNS ANLO MARPO FUR
IN THE AREA TO THEKNY PEOPLE HA
DIED IN THAT AREA THAT I
KED.
LE V.
IT AND OTHER TOWNSTY
TROYED.
SO IFBO
NO
AS TO R MILITARYT OF THE
NUMBERS WE HAVE, WE
WE L2,50 3ITTHN
MILITARY